الحب ثم الزواج ثم الاسره ثم الاطفال هذه
المراحل مراحل حياتيه تعزز الترابط
والتفاهم قرار التخلي عنها قاسم دائمه
دائما يعادل بالفعل الحديث اليوم مشاهدينا
هنا عن الطلاق هو صعب على طرفي الزواج
وصعب اكثر ربما على الابناء اذا كان هذا
الابن في السن حتى لو كان في سنه 60 او سن
الاربعين لكن بات لدينا فكره عن المرحله
الاصعب للاطفال فيما يتعلق بالطلاق وهي
المرحله الابتدائيه
موقع
هيلف هيلف لاين عفوا
نشر دراسه حددت ان الاطفال في سن
الابتدائيه هم كبار بما يكفي لتذكر
الاوقات الجيده
وسيتساءلون عن دورهم في الطلاق ربما
سيشعرون بالذنب بالفعل بحسب هذه الدراسه
مشاهدينا يمكن ان تؤدي هذه المشاعر الى
اكتئاب الاطفال كما يمكن ان تؤثر عليهم
مستقبلا ليصبح الطفل منعزلا وغير متواصل
وقلق
زميلتنا راح تشاركنا معلومات اكثر حول
الدراسه واثر الطلاق على الاطفال في كل
مرحله عمريه لميس
الطلاق يمكن ان يكون له اثار دائمه على
اطفالك ولكن اثره يختلف بحسب الفئه
العمريه فتحت السن الثالثه قد يتذكر
الاطفال بالفعل الخلافات بين الابوين
عندما كانوا في الثانيه من العمر ولكن
بحلول الوقت الذي يكبرون فيه قليلا قد
ينسونها لكن هذه القضايا يمكن ان تسبب
مشاكل لاحقه
مرحله ما قبل المدرسه اي من ثلاث الى خمس
سنوات اذا كان الوالدان يتشاجران فقد يشعر
الاطفال في هذا العمر بقوه ان علمهم
يتعرضوا للاهتزاز وقد تتحسن الامور بالفعل
بعد الطلاق عندما يعود الاستقرار الى
المنزل وبمجرد وضع الروتين يمكن لطفلك ان
يبدا في الشعور بالسيطره مجددا
ان المدرسه الابتدائيه تحديدا من سن 6
سنوات الى 12 عاما يمكن القول ان هذا هو
اصعب سن للاطفال للتعامل مع انفصال او
طلاق والديهم هذا لانهم سيتساءلون عن
دورهم في الطلاق ويميلون الى جعل الامر
يتعلق بهم اما المراهقون فغالبا ما يكونون
متمركزين حول الذات وعلى عكس الاطفال في
سن الابتدائيه يدور عالمهم عاده حول
حياتهم خارج المنزل ومن غير المرجح انهم
يشعرون بانهم مخطئون في الطلاق لذا ياتي
القبول لطلاق بسهوله اكبر ونحن سالنا
الناس في العراق ما اسوا عمر للطلاق الاهل
بالنسبه للاطفال برايك نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
بين الخامسه والخامسه عشر بكونوا
الطلاق بين الوالدين بيكون سلبي جدا على
الاطفال بحكم انه صغار بيكونوا متعلقين
باولاده بعد العاشره خاصه دور المراهقه
يكون اكثر تاثيرا
لحالات الطلاق الصغير بين الام وبين الاب
كون ثلاث سنوات حدث ثمان سنوات لان هي
فتره اساس الطفل اللي هي تعلم عن صغر
كالنقشه على الحجر احنا المفروض ننقل
تجربه جاي يصير في اغلب البلدان العربيه
منها مصر اليوم ما تسمح بالطلاق اذا كانت
طفل عمره لا يتعدى سبع سنوات
والله انا اشوف الفتره اللي تحسس بيها
الطفليه فتت المراهقه من عشر سنين الى 18
سنه لازم يعني يكون الاب والام موجودين
[موسيقى]
معنى الام مشاهدينا في الاستوديو
الاختصاصيه النفسيه اللي هنا حداد اهلا بك
علينا معنا
في صباح الخير سهله الينا دراسه تتحدث اذا
عن
يعني ما بدنا نقول العمر الانسب لطلاق
الاهل بالنسبه للاطفال ولكن الاكثر خطوره
مع ذلك الطلاق يؤثر بشكل كبير على الاطفال
بكل المراحل العمريه كيف تختلف ما بين اذا
كانوا صغار جدا رغم انه ما يجري في الصغر
يبقى معنا طوال العمر
ويعني بعض السنوات الى الامام يصبح الطلاق
اصعب او اسهل بالنسبه للاطفال
هلا لا شك انه الطلاق هو كثير صعب على
الاطفال شو ما يكون عمرهم من الطفوله
للمراهقه لا لما يصيروا اكبر
اللي بتفرق انه بالطفوله الولد مش دايما
بيتذكر كل شيء
بخصوص اذا هذا عفوا
هي اهم شي تكون الطريقه طريقه الطلاق بين
الاهل طريقه التعامل بين بعض هيدا من اول
من اساسيات التاثير اذا بدك على الاطفال
بمرحله الطفوله الطفل بحاجه للرعايه بحاجه
للاهتمام لما يكون عم يوصل لهذا الشيء من
اهله لو عم بيكون في طلاق بين الاتنين راح
يكون اهتمامه اذا بدك او تركيزه اكثر على
الرعايه اللي عم ياخذها من اهله كرمال هيك
بنقول انه مش كثير بتاثر بس طبعا ما بيعني
انه ما بيتذكر
بكل الاحوال يتذكر يعني ما هي هذه القرار
اذا كان قد اتخذ بين الاباء كيف من الممكن
ان نخفف ذلك الضرر على الابناء بمعنى انه
هل في
الروضه او الكي جي هل في عمر كبير بانه
انا اقعد واشرح لهم ام انه لا
الضرر واقع اذا كانوا كبار وهم صغار ما
يتذكرون هذه المواقف القديمه او هذه حاله
الانفصال
اما ديما الاهل يجربوا قد اذا بدك يوصلوا
لهم الفكره بطريقه يعني اذا بدك اروق
طريقه ممكن تكون طبعا هلا بتفرق بين العمر
والعمر كيف يخبرون يعني تفاصيل ولا مرات
تفاصيل حسب هون بتفرق العمر بس كطريقه اهم
شيء كيف بيتواصلوا مع بعض الاهل يعني الام
والبيت خصوصي لما يكون في مشاكل يعني اذا
ما يكون في مشاكل ما تصير قدام الاولاد شو
ما يكون عمرهم او يعملوا الطفل اذا بدك
اذا بدك
يعني بالنص يعني مثلا خبر امك خبر بيك
بحبك الاخر امام الطفل طبعا وكمان لما
يصيروا يتدخلوا العيال من الطرفين هو بشكل
ضغط كثير كبير على الطفل طيب الينا اذا
الدراسه تتحدث عن انه المرحله الابتدائيه
هي الاكثر خطرا بالنسبه للاطفال ممكن انه
يصابوا باكتئاب وضعهم يكون صعب جدا من
جراء طلاق ذويهم ولكن والدهم ووالد تهم
ولكن شو الضرر اللي ممكن يكون على الاطفال
في حال هالقد العلاقه صعبه ما بين الزوج
والزوجه وقرروا الاستمرار فيها عشان
الاطفال طبعا نحن دائما بننتقل انه لما
يكون في كوبل او لما يكون في زوج وزوجه
بدهم يطلقوا بس بيقولوا لنا هل افضل انه
نبقى كرمل للاطفال
ننتظر يعني كم سنه مئه بالمئه هو طبعا لا
لانه الاطفال فيهم يكونوا دافع للاهل
ليجربوا يصلحوا الامور من بعض بس طبعا هن
مانهم سبب لحتى يبقوا مع بعض بالبيت لانه
بنكون بس عم نتجاهل المشكله ولما نتجاهل
المشكله اذا بدك مع الوقت رح تتفاقم طبعا
وراح تصير اكبر وتاثيرها اكثر فنحن دائما
منجرب انه الاهل يحلوا ما شكلهم لوحدهم في
حال ما مشي الحال ما مشي الحال وقرروا
ينفصلوا ساعتها خلص القرار لازم يؤخذ انه
ينفصلوا باقل ضرر ممكن شكرا الينا احداد
الاختصاصيه النفسيه يعطيك العافيه
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات